from the United Kingdom here is Oscar
nominee for closer Clive Owen and
Academy Award winner and a nominee
tonight Cate Blanchett
here are the nominees for the best
foreign language film after the wedding
from Denmark Susana beer days of glory
indigent from Algeria Rashid Buescher
the lives of others from Germany florian
henckel von donnersmarck Pan's Labyrinth
from Mexico
guillermo del toro water from canada
deeper mater and the Oscar goes to sorry
um Germany for the lives of others
this is the second Academy Award in
seventh nomination for Germany Germany's
last nominations were in 2005 and 2004
for the films of Sophie Scholl the final
days and downfall
oh my god
I was I was already crying after Jonah
tOA's film and hey I thank you Academy
members from the bottom of my heart for
this honor and I thank Michael and Tom
from Sony classics for choosing the
lives of others and and bringing it to
you
I thank Germany and Bavaria for making
this film possible my my great
department heads for making this film
with me
Schwarzenegger for teaching me that the
words I can't should be stricken from my
vocabulary I'm and my entire crew I
thank my producers commissioning editors
distributors finance tears um
I thank my brother Sebastian for helping
with the script and ho Bamba for
believing in me but most of all I thank
my actors especially early in the
busting you are the greatest artists and
don't let anybody tell you otherwise
finally my wife Cassie Anna no I have to
say that one more thing just that one
more thing cuz Jana I love you
okay
okay I just want to try something real
real quick if somebody would just turn
that light on back here I think this
will be fun no yeah
it's a snake on a plane get it it's a
doggy doggy cupboard wait wait we thank
you very much thank you thank you oh oh
hey hey hey
okay all right
okay
you
they're naked
you